bon auc au
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Winter ok personne n'est parfait On A
Il ne nous reste plus qu'à mettre en cache Ok
on pré s'isoler Ne pas s'en
par personne Ne le plaisir solitaire
ce cliché
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai facilité
deel fait le
[Musique]
m ok dans La société on n'est pas un
dieu vraiment respecté PR dans
l'obscurité IL est
glorifi est mieux gardé on Ne dit pas le
mot ch on fait comme si rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
était
que la terre est sur un baiser de
quelques secondes tout le monde a dit
tout tout le
[Musique]
monde
est tout le monde
fa la ter tout monde
fa tout
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monde tout le monde tout le monde que le
terre est r Sur Un baiser de quelqu'un
Second tout le monde tout fait tout le
monde
monde sur un
les tout tout le monde
tout sur les
[Musique]
MS.
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le mois
messieurs bravo
Bravo